less than a billion years ago life
crossed a threshold single cells started
to band together eventually evolving
into the riot of shapes and functions of
multicellular life today it's been
thought that the evolution of
multicellularity must have been a major
genetic leap but new research suggests
that it wasn't such a difficult
transition after all scientists looked
at an organism that seems closest to
making this leap
Carano flageolets while single-celled
resemble the specialized cells that line
the channels of sponges which are
considered by many to be the most
primitive living animal a lab found 350
gene families in Kona flageolets once
thought to be exclusive to multicellular
animals the findings suggest that this
single-celled organism is already
equipped for multicellular life
a single cells life is simple but
limited like Hermits microbes need only
be concerned with feeding themselves in
contrast cells in a multicellular
organism give up their independence they
take on specialized functions they
sacrifice their progeny for the greater
good
take vulvar and algae which comes in a
spectrum of cellularity a lab compared
the biology and genetics of this diverse
set of algae and learned that as cells
banded together existing genes took on
new functions clam atom Onis is a
single-celled algae that uses its
centrioles for both swimming and
reproduction so it can't do both at the
same time it's multicellular relative
Volvox however can do both at once
because its cells have specialized with
some using the centriole for swimming
and others using it for reproduction
yeast is a fungus consisting of a single
cell one lab conducted a series of test
tube experiments with yeast cultures to
better understand how cells evolved
increasing complexity the biggest cells
which were the ones that settle to the
bottom of the flask were allowed to
survive and reproduce within two months
daughter cells stuck to their mothers
and form multicellular structures
dubbed snowflakes because of their shape
over time they got bigger and more and
more complex in this sped up simulation
of evolution the yeast specialized cells
in large snowflakes certain cells
undergo a type of suicide releasing the
cells at the tip to start a new
snowflake the dying cell sacrifices its
life so that the group can reproduce a
hallmark of multicellularity the team
conducted the same experiment with
chlamydomonas and again a kind of
multicellularity was quick to appear
scientists are still debating what drove
simple cells to become more and more
complex but with these genetic
comparisons and clever experiments what
was once thought as a major leap can now
be seen as a series of small genetic
steps that led to the wondrous diversity
of multicellular life today
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]